الرئيس بايدن يستهل فترة ولايته
بإصدار تقرير المخابرات الأمريكية
أم في مقتل
الصحفي الأمريكي المقيم جمال
خاشقجي ، امتنع الرئيس عن
معاقبة ولي العهد
مباشرة على مقتل شكشي ، ومع ذلك تم فرض عقوبات
على عدد
من المسؤولين السعوديين و  قالت
الإدارة إن
العلاقات السعودية بحاجة إلى
إعادة تقويم ، وأنا أقتبس منه
ما هو الدليل حتى الآن على
إعادة المعايرة هذه وكيف تصف
العلاقات الحالية مع الولايات المتحدة ،
وسأصف علاقاتنا بأنها قوية ،
فهي تعكس
علاقة تاريخية قوية عبر العديد من
الإدارات  كل من الجمهوري
والديمقراطي يعود إلى الآن أكثر من 75
عامًا ولدينا أجندة مشتركة قوية مع
العديد من قضايا التعاون أه
نواصل العمل على
الأمن الإقليمي
أه في مقدمتها
ولدينا حوار قوي مستمر بين
أه المملكة  وإدارة الانقسام
بما في ذلك
الاتصالات المتكررة مع زملائنا  خوف
في الولايات المتحدة وأه ما نسمعه
هو أن هناك الكثير من مجالات
الاتفاق
أممم ، على سبيل المثال أحد المجالات التي
نعمل عليها عن كثب
هي اليمن والإحضار وإلى
الصراع هناك وأين
أعلنا  أه المبادرة السعودية
لوقف إطلاق النار
وهو أمر أه قمنا
بتنسيقه عن كثب مع
الإدارة وكذلك مارتن
غريفيث وأنت تعلم أننا نواصل
العمل عن كثب على العديد من الملفات الأخرى لذلك
هناك
حوار قوي ومستمر
بين الاثنين
تعرب الدول عن ارتياحها لأن إدارة بايدن
لم
تذهب إلى أبعد من ذلك في هذه المرحلة في الاقتباس
لإعادة ضبط العلاقة وأي
عقوبات أخرى على سبيل المثال ضد ولي
العهد نفسه ،
أعتقد أن مظاهرة العروس ترى
أن العلاقة مع
المملكة العربية السعودية هي مفتاح تمامًا
مصالح الولايات المتحدة وأولوياتنا في
المنطقة وخارجها ،
وهم يدركون أن العمل مع
المملكة يتطلب العمل
معنا ومعنا  القيادة
وسنواصل الحوار حول أفضل السبل لتقديم الأفضل
لكلا بلدينا وللتأكد من خدمة مصالحنا
وأننا نقدم
أه الفوائد التي لدينا على مدى
العقود
لنتحدث عن أهمية أه
هذا  العلاقة
في هذه المرحلة ، كما
أشرت بحق ،
نحن منخرطون بشدة في محاولة إيجاد
حل للصراع
في اليمن ، لقد جعلوا اليمن أولوية مطلقة ولتحقيق
هذه الغاية
عملوا معك في
المملكة لتقديمها.  عرض وقف إطلاق النار
للمتمردين الحوثيين والذي قلته أنت بنفسك
يمكن أن يمهد الطريق
لحل سياسي مقتبس
للصراع هناك
أظهر الحوثيون أي إشارات بأنهم على
استعداد للانخراط
مع المملكة
حتى الآن رأينا أه استمرار
الهجمات عبر بلادنا.  الحدود بما في ذلك
هجمات على أهداف مدنية أه
وبنيتها التحتية
ونراهم مستمرون في مهاجمة مأرب
لذا فالمؤشرات أنهم
مازالوا غير جديين في
التكين.  الخطوات اللازمة
لنقل هذا
الصراع إلى مرحلة سياسية
ومع ذلك فإننا نواصل الدفع إلى الأمام
ونواصل دفع
اقتراحنا للأمام ونحن منخرطون
لقد
عملنا عن كثب مع
كل من مارتن
غريفيث وتيم ليندركند.  على اتصال
مع الحوثيين لمحاولة
إقناعهم بأن
وضع المصالح الفضلى لليمن في المقام
الأول أمر
حاسم وأساسي وأنه يجب علينا جميعًا
العمل معًا
للتأكد من أن هذا الصراع ينتقل
الآن إلى عملية سياسية
سلطت الضوء على استمرار هجمات
الحوثيين.
أه على المملكة
وبنيتها التحتية هل
سترفعون وقف إطلاق النار المقترح
عن الطاولة إذا استمرت تلك الهجمات
لا نحن ملتزمون بوقف
إطلاق النار ووقف إطلاق النار بالطبع
يتطلب أه جميع الأطراف أه وقف إطلاق
النار
أه وبمجرد أن يوافق الحوثيون على ذلك نحن
ذاهبون  لنكون أه ملتزمون بالاستمرار
في
دفع عملية الحل السياسي أه
لن نأخذ
أه أه وقف إطلاق النار من علامة التبويب  لو أه
لكننا سندافع
عن
خلايانا ، سنتأكد من حماية شعبنا وبنيتنا التحتية وسندعم أيضًا حكومة اليمن إذا شجع الحوثيون
قرار إدارة بايدن التراجع عن قرار
دونالد ترامب أه
بتخصيصهم  كان
هذا خطأ من جانب الإدارة الأمريكية الجديدة ،
نشعر بالتأكيد أن الحوثيين
يستحقون أن يتم تصنيفهم كمنظمة إرهابية
،
لقد هاجموا أهدافًا مدنية
وخطفوا أشخاصًا واستخدموا
الإرهاب لفرض إرادتهم
على الشعب اليمني.  واه نعتقد
أن
هذا التصنيف كان صحيحًا
الآن نحن نفهم
منطق إدارة بايدن في إزالته
ولكن بالطبع
رأينا ارتفاعًا في الهجمات منذ أن
تم عكس هذا التعيين سواء كان
هذان الشيئان مرتبطين
وهذا سيكون تكهنات ولكن هذا
بالتأكيد شيء
يمكن تخمين الأطفال الحوثيين بشكل جيد
بالطبع يصر على أن أي
صفقة يجب أن تتضمن a  -
موافقة المملكة على رفع
الحصار البحري والجوي عن
ميناء الحديدة الاستراتيجي هذا ، وتدعم الأمم المتحدة وبرنامج الغذاء العالمي
إنهاء حصار التجديد
والتحقيق الذي كشف أن
السفن الحربية السعودية
منعت جميع الناقلات من
الرسو بالميناء كما نفهمه.
سيتم الآن السماح لأربع سفن وقود
بالرسو في دادا ، وصل أولها
الأسبوع الماضي ، وهل يمكنك تقديم المزيد من
التفاصيل حول ذلك وهل هذا
ترتيب مؤقت أم أن
المملكة
ترفع هذا الهواء رسميًا وترى
الحصار
وبالتالي الوضع الإنساني في اليمن
أه
أه بالطبع اعتبار رئيسي
لنا جميعاً بما في ذلك
المملكة العربية السعودية نحن من أه
نحن أول متبرع أه لليمن
التزمنا بإعطاء 420 مليون
دولار هذا العام بالإضافة له
هناك  لا يوجد حصار في آخر 90 يومًا ،
رست 67 سفينة في الحديدة
، وهناك تدفق مستمر للسلع
والخدمات عبر الحديدة
وعبر أربعة معابر حدودية و
كذلك هناك ميناءان آخران يعملان ،
فالوضع مع سفن الوقود مرتبط
باتفاقية بين
الحوثيين والحكومة اليمنية تتعلق
بكيفية أه عائدات الضرائب من تلك
السفن للأسف يواصل الحوثيون
عدم
التمسك بذلك.  الاتفاق وقد
استخدموا هذه الأموال
لدعم جهودهم العسكرية
بما في ذلك هجومهم المستمر
على مدينة معجبة بها أكثر من مليوني
نازح داخليًا
الآن وافقت الحكومة اليمنية
على السماح لهذه
السفن الأربع بالدخول ونحن ندعم بالتأكيد
أننا ندعم ذلك.  هذا
أمر جيد ومن الأهمية بمكان أن
نجد طريقة عمل بين
الحوثيين والحكومة اليمنية
تضمن استمرار دخول سفن الوقود هذه
واستخدام عائدات
سفن الوقود هذه على
النحو الذي اتفق عليه الحوثيون في اتفاقية ستوكهولم
للتمويل.  الخدمات المدنية وغيرها
من الأمور التي
يحتاجها أهل اليمن
بدلاً من تحويل تلك الأموال أه
إلى  جهودنا الحربية لذلك سنواصل
العمل للتأكد من
استمرار تدفق الوقود ولكن فيما وراء
سفن الوقود بشكل عام ، يمكن للسفن الوصول إلى الأحاديث
النبوية وكما قلت 67 سفينة في 90
يومًا الماضية وسيستمر ذلك لذا فإن
الحصار على هذا
الوقود  السفن التي يتم رفعها ليس
ترتيبًا مؤقتًا كما أفهمها
منك ،
هذا هو هذا الآن
سيتم السماح برفع هذا الحصار الذي ستسمح به سفن الوقود هذه
بالاستمرار في الرسو ، هل هذا صحيح
لا
يوجد حصار هناك آلية  مع
الأمم المتحدة تم الاتفاق مع
الأمم المتحدة على السماح للسفن بدخول
الحديدة وتلك الآلية
مستمرة
كما قلت على سفن الوقود كانت هناك
مشكلة بين الحكومة
اليمنية والحوثيين حيث
لم يلتزم الحوثيون بتعهداتهم.  و
نتج عن ذلك تأخير في دخول
السفن
طالما استمر الحوثيون في الالتزام
بنصيبهم من الاتفاق و استخدامهم
لتلك الأموال أه
كما تم الاتفاق عليه في ستوكهولم
لا ينبغي أن تكون هناك مشكلة
ونفترض أن حكومة اليمن
ستستمر في منح موافقتها على
هذه الرحلات الميدانية لمواصلة الدخول.
أريد أن أتحدث عن إسرائيل قبل يومين
من انتخاب إسرائيل ،
أشار بنيامين نتنياهو إلى
أن
تطبيع العلاقات مع المملكة العربية السعودية
يمكن أن يكون
وشيكًا القول في الإذاعة الوطنية أنه
سيكون لدينا رحلات مباشرة
للحجاج الإسرائيليين المسلمين من تل أبيب إلى مكة
بشكل علني. لم تغير المملكة
موقفها وتقول إن تطبيع
العلاقات
لن يتحقق إلا بعد التوصل إلى اتفاق سلام
مع الفلسطينيين في المملكة.
فتحت مجالها الجوي لإسرائيل
منذ سبتمبر / أيلول من العام الماضي ،
وبالطبع يشترك البلدان
في عدو مشترك في إيران.
لا أعرف ما إذا كان الأمر وشيكًا فهو يعتمد إلى حد
كبير على التقدم في
عملية أه السلام ، لذلك هناك بالطبع أ
صفقة التطبيع مطروحة على الطاولة منذ
2002 تسمى خطة السلام العربية وحتى
قبل ذلك كانت لدينا مبادرة فاس
التي
كانت أه أه قدمتها المملكة عام
والتي أه تطرح آفاق
التطبيع الكامل والتام مع
إسرائيل مقابل تسوية عادلة
للقضية الفلسطينية
أعتقد أن تطبيع وضع إسرائيل
داخل المنطقة
سيحقق فائدة
كبيرة للمنطقة ككل سيكون
أهأه
مفيد على الصعيدين الاقتصادي
والاجتماعي والأمني
ن بعد أه التطبيع  في المنطقة
لا يمكن أن تنجح إلا إذا
عالجنا أه قضية الفلسطينيين وإذا
تمكنا من
إقامة دولة فلسطينية ضمن حدود 1967
تمنح الفلسطينيين الكرامة
وتعطيهم
حقوقهم إذا تمكنا من إيجاد طريق
نحو
ذلك فأنا  نعتقد أننا يمكن أن نرى
منطقة أكثر أمانًا بكثير
ومنطقة مزدهرة أكثر بكثير عندما
يمكن للجميع المساهمة
في نجاحها  ess بما في ذلك
إسرائيل وأنت ترحب بفكرة
الرحلات الجوية المباشرة للحجاج الإسرائيليين المسلمين من
تل أبيب إلى مكة ، فأنت لم
ترحب فقط بموافقتك على أن تجعلك
دولة أه أه لم نوافق على
ذلك ولكن
كما  قلت إذا كان لدينا تقدم أه في
القضية الإسرائيلية الفلسطينية ،
فأنت تعلم أننا نأمل أن نرحب
بالمواطنين الإسرائيليين من جميع
الأديان أه في المملكة ليس فقط
المسلمين ولكن
تعلمون دعونا نمضي قدمًا في
عملية السلام أولاً ، ما الذي يتطلبه
الأمر بالفعل  احصل على الموافقة على هذه الرحلات الجوية ، هل
هي خطة كاملة في
هذه المرحلة لأنني أفكر في
أن النافذة هنا قصيرة جدًا ،
لذا هل هناك نوع من الاقتراح المخفف
الذي قد تقبله المملكة في هذه المرحلة
من أجل
تحريك هذا النوع من المشكلات أه ،
أعني الآن أننا نتحدث عن
افتراضي ، لذلك
لا يوجد شيء يمكنني إضافته إليه حقًا